you know one of the reasons i enjoy our
friendship so much is that you bring
this russian thing
you know which i don't really understand
it at a deep level how could i i'm not
russian but
um
but this mindset like that there's pain
in life when i watched that uh hedgehog
in the fog
cartoon i thought no wonder russians
call it the way they do this is the most
depre it's so sad it's beautiful and
savage so sad whereas out here it's like
sesame street and you know my mother
would not let me watch sesame street
when i was a kid yes she thought it was
too chaotic
she was chaos too chaotic she was like
it's too chaotic too many things going
on captain kangaroo we were allowed and
then mr rogers we were allowed i never
really liked shows i like doing things
in outside in the in the yard um i was
trying to trap all the animals i didn't
want to watch stuff on tv but you know
hedgehog in the fog is enough to turn
any kid into a thinker and a philosopher
and a poet here we go
i fell in love with this when when you
showed look it even walks with its arms
behind its back so for people don't know
and we're watching
little clips here to get into and it's a
hedgehog
that
is wandering about in this fog at night
and you can't even see a lamp the fog is
so and there's a there's a feeling of
searching
and then there's a there's a horse that
speaks from from a distance
words of wisdom some people actually
told me that they believe that's god
that's supposed to represent
god i always thought it was a motherly
voice or a voice
a voice of conformity that wants you to
return to safety and here's a
the hedgehog is searching
for something that's in him
for the unknown to the explore the
unknown and ultimately as it
um as the cartoon unrolls it's
he discovers a friend
in a bear
and he also discovers a lifetime passion
for looking up at the stars and the
curiosity of exploring what is up there
and i see that as science as exploring
the mystery
and also i see that as brave
to explore the mystery given all the
uncertainty all around you but there is
a melancholy the whole sound of it the
feel of it the look of it it was um
it just captures
both the melancholy and the wander of
childhood
which is like
there's a loneliness to it like nobody
understands me
uh
that's there that that children can con
can feel because you're you're trying to
figure out what's my favorite character
right there i love the owl i love the
owl
the owl shows up every once in a while i
love the owl sorry i i interrupted you
there's again there's non-sequitur it
means you're interested seventy percent
of the time
the other thirty percent you're just an
[ __ ] so you have to figure out what
you said so i'm told
the uh there's non-secular parts in this
cartoon it's voted as one of the
greatest cartoons of all time short
short little films documentary
filmmakers it's a it is uh you know in
the soviet union in
in a lot of sort of
authoritarian regimes
there's channels to communicate
difficult ideas
to people and you figure out those
channels and in soviet union one of
those channels was
uh children's cartoons
so you're actually they're very much for
adults
yeah i i like that um
in some countries not so much in the us
uh
children are treated with more respect
for their intelligence
you know
and not constantly getting this drivel
of of just kind of moronic explosions
and whistles and bells and the voices
that um just kind of you know children
obviously are children and need to be
their brains are young and plastic and
need to be
treated and nurtured uh as such but they
but they have an intelligence and i
think that um you treat them like morons
and and they're gonna behave like morons
you treat them as you know people who
can
uh consume information and make sense of
it in their own way and
that's what they're gonna do they have a
seriousness of looking at the world i
love people
that talk with children like they're
adults
we'll just like here's if you're talking
to minnie einstein
because you're like really
uh they're asking some big questions and
i think uh i mean people sometimes
uh
speak of me in this way like
how dumb is this childlike person but
like no no there's intelligence in these
dumb simple questions
in like that a child asks and i always
love those questions the simplicity but
also the depth of the those those
questions the one reason i started
watching your podcast was you did an
episode early on with ray dalio yeah and
the first maybe the first but a question
that you definitely asked him was you
just said
what is money and his answer was
fantastic it's an it's a superb question
and he gave a superb answer
and
i never would have thought to ask that
question
and it's it's the question and it was
the question to tee things off with
um
so simple
questions that get right to the heart of
the matter
you know and kids aren't often putting
the same uh cultural filters and
um
you know they're not kids gen generally
aren't concerned about getting canceled
either
so they'll ask the question that no one
else is willing to ask and they're not
concerned about the how
dumb the question
sounds i find the most fascinating
questions just really really simple and
it is a bit embarrassing
to ask those simple questions of what
like what is
well anything you're asking them for all
of us so please ask them um i think that
question what is money is crucial and
i think the simple questions are the
most obviously the most interesting
you